no matter what industry you ran there's
gonna be pre crisis before crisis post
crisis with businesses so let's just say
you're in the restaurant business let's
just say you're in the real estate
business let's just say you're on the
commercial real estate PNC auto
insurance it doesn't matter what
business you're in dry cleaners I don't
care what it is and there's a lot of
different types of businesses within
your community 5 10 15 20 miles and
they're all competing for the same
market share it doesn't have to be 20
months it may be another business but
they're all competing for the same
market share you got Alan's restaurant
bobby's you know a Greek restaurant
Charlie sushi it doesn't matter they're
within the same 5 10 mile radius free
everyone's doing okay this person gets 7
percent of market share 14 percent of
market share 19 percent of you get the
idea
pre they're all in business post 3 them
go out of business
a CNF a used to be a good size they
couldn't handle during pandemic they ran
out of savings they're gone
C is gone F is gone what happened B got
even bigger they got a big market share
of a e got bigger he got a chunk of C G
got bigger G got a part of F D got a
little bit bigger because they got a
little bit of F I got a little bit
smaller because G got a part of my you
get the idea what happens it even H got
a little bit bigger themselves this
happens to every industry now why is
this many times you and I hear about the
survival of the fittest right oh this is
all about the survival of the fittest
that may be true years ago two dates
about the survival of the strategist and
strategists are about what they do
during times like this so let me explain
we talked about earlier there's gonna be
three different types of businesses
those who shut down those who survive
those who become stronger the ideal go
for you is to become stronger when this
whole thing pans out right this whole
thing ends so now seven things to do
during times like this number one while
these businesses are going out of
business you have to realize that within
these companies of a C and F there's a
lot of strong talent who are now free
agents they're looking to see where they
take their talents imagine how much
social capital they happen within the
industry acquire a quiz
during times like this if you've sat
pretty you've raised money you have cash
there's a lot of opportunities to pick
up other businesses next one here third
one is focus and minimize and explore
what I mean by focus or minimize there
could have been an issue with a because
a was trying to be everything for
everybody you know how you go to some
restaurants and they're selling like
every sushi and chicken and burgers you
know like this kind of several do what
do you do it just sell your sushi Oh at
our place we're doing Mediterranean and
Korean food right it's what we're doing
over here you go to certain oh we do
real estate and we do auto insurance and
we do tax and we do more here just and
we do but the real specialty has always
been tax what their specialty has always
been real estate and mortgages this is
about specializing today and being
focused today times like this force the
CEO and the entrepreneur and the
partners to say listen why are we trying
to go do all these different businesses
let's get focused into what we are good
at number four tech phenomenal time to
mess them to tech why a couple reasons
one engineers need work and by the way
engineers can code from anywhere they
don't need to be out of at your house
they don't need to be at your office
they can be coding from Armenia number
five strategic partnership phenomenal
time for strategic partnership let me
put it to you this way my phone if you
were to look at my phone right now I
have people calling me on Friday nights
at midnight who cannot stand me in my
industry as a competitor when I used to
be small they loved us the moment we
became big they couldn't stand us and
now they're calling me telling me hey
how can we do business together and I
said why are you calling me I thought I
was an enemy well you know it's not like
that it's just one we're competing I
can't tell everybody how great you know
you are what you do because my guys are
gonna want to go work with you you know
the game I mean let's not act like we
don't know the amount fine no problem
set the ego side creating uh strategic
partnerships today there's plenty of
those opportunities if you can set the
ego set because there's a lot of that
going on today number six over
communication with clients create time
to over communicate with your client we
did more zooms with all our executive
team
dirty than ever before because it's a
form of over communication today
everybody was seen that there's a level
of confidence on what's going on today
and last but not least I'll give you
it's social issues a guy named Sam who's
an Armenian guy young guy who runs a
digital media company he says Pat I'm a
little bit concerned I said what are you
concern about he says look I run this
little agency digital media agency and
I'm doing pretty good but this whole
thing shut me down I don't know what to
do I'm calling my guys my customers to
run some ads but they don't want to run
ads because they said no one's behind
their products today so whatever I said
no promise said listen this is what I'd
be doing if I were you shoes he said
what is that
I said businesses today have to find a
way to be relevant he said okay how do
you do it I said you need to be thinking
about that dry cleaner that was spending
$3,000 a month with you how can you make
him stay relevant in his customers eyes
maybe they can do certain social issues
what kind of social issues I don't know
what matters to them find out their
cause
have them matched together maybe a way
of supporting their customers maybe tell
us a family member or somebody that's
really going through challenging times
it could be something where you know
tell us a single mother right now that's
staying home with the kids and they're
having a hard time we want to send
something to them and hey here's a care
package it could be something where it's
a Amazon car the target something you
can do where you brighten someones day
and its social it's masks whatever may
be so many different ways of doing it
that's a great time to do it today we
look at Arnold Schwarzenegger and all
the success he had in bodybuilding he
was able to translate into other areas
of his life the success that you had
early in wrestling you've obviously been
able to translate what what's sort of
the secret for you to to the level of
success event you know it's interesting
how similar my wrestling mindset and
businesses it's not same a lot of people
in fact I've had a lot of people last
years I've kind of rub rubbed the wrong
way because of it but I look at it as a
sports like when I started my business I
was looking around the first thing I
looked at was like who do I have to be I
remember when we came in there was a
software company it was like all right
that's our competitor and it was like I
wasn't quiet about either made known to
myself to my team to my entire community
we're gonna beat them and then we went
after I'm aggressive ly aggressively in
and just like I would if I was gonna be
wrestling or competing against and I
like I reversed injured everything they
did I figure out what they were doing
why they're doing listen to every
podcast interview the founders on but
understand his mindset what he was doing
and we we just like relentlessly pursued
them until we caught them and then we
passed them and if we passed them that I
was like it's funny because I was like I
need something new to go after and then
there was another company that was
bigger than then I was like hey that's
the next company we started going after
him the same thing I pursue them and
like looked at a reverse engineer
they're doing and how they're doing and
why they were doing and trying to figure
it out and I remember as we started
getting closer and closer to them the
CEO of that company called me one day
and he was like he said why are you so
upset at like why do you hate me and I
hate our company so much I kind of
caught me off guard like what do you
mean he's like he's like you were out
there always like trying to like you
know do all he seems to beat us and I
was like oh I don't hate you guys at all
I got patrece back like I know more
about you than I think you do like I
understand what you doing why you love I
don't believe you do
I don't hate you at all but but you're
my competitor if you're who I chose I
have to beat you like that's that's how
it works and he was like I'm every came
back and he's like I he's like I wasn't
really an athlete so I'm not used to
that like he's like it's interesting I
thought you mad you're mad at he hated
that sounds like no like it might be the
scene in my favorite movies the dark
night where the very end Joker's falling
off the cliff and Batman asking is like
he's why are you trying to kill me and
the Joker starts laughing is like I'm
not trying to kill he was like he's like
without you like there's no me like I
can't do what I do without you and I
feel like that that that's been such my
mindset and in fact you know that we
passed that company it's like hey who's
the next people we found who they are
and I'm studying them and understanding
him in a deeper level and like and so
for me it's I don't think I could be in
business versus the businesses to to
grow or I don't know the data without a
goal or purpose or something to strive
towards and to move move move forward
I was member reading them things
Napoleon Bonaparte said something about
what man will do for a first scrap of
ribbon I feel like maybe that's like in
wrestling that's what it was for me like
I had it like I'd to go and I went to it
I was a state champ there was an
all-american like I kept going for the
whatever the next scrap of ribbon I had
to get it and I feel like in business
it's the same thing for me it's just
like it's a game there's competitors and
we're trying to figure out the landscape
where we fit in and how we how we pursue
and how we go after them we're all in
at a time right now and I'm actually
very lucky though to be working in the
food industry and so as a food blogger a
lot of people are turning to food for
comfort or you know all the reasons so
for me I've had record number of
pageviews record number of profile
visits record number of people like
remaking my recipes yet my struggle
right now is how do I get brands to
actually want to do sponsored work
because all of a sudden March 10th
March 11 like just came screeching to a
halt like nobody wants to do that
anymore you don't food companies are
tightening up you know you know
yesterday one of our clients emailed us
and said we're not paying you this is
seven figures and you're getting fired
and we might be going bankrupt you don't
get that you don't get to effect the
other side what you do right now is a
hopefully you either saved or you're
humble enough to go backwards and this
is for everybody be you go ham on
producing as much content doing as many
lives going across every platform even
trying even waiting to do tick-tock
you've been waiting to do Twitter you do
all that now you build up so in 180 days
when she's truly back to normal you're
getting that this is chess right now not
checkers it's not direct it's macro so
go ham like all in like so many people
are dwelling I've heard from a thousand
of you already yeah like Gary I'm
crushing but all my money's gone because
the brands aren't sponsoring I'm like
uh-huh I'm like remember when I told you
if there was a recession like
influencers wouldn't be as fun anymore
yes good news this a fake recession aka
it doesn't have the underlining
principles to be something super long
it's likely we'll get back to normal
somewhere here later I mean the biggest
the biggest elephant in the room is if
this reopened winter like some experts
are saying then you're starting to get
into some but but if not then you know
we're gonna be back to normal somewhere
in the next 90 120 160 180 days I think
you need to build build build big bill
and then take the opportunities when
they come I'm playing a game that most
people really don't understand I'm
playing a network game you know and
independent game most people don't
understand what that means but you know
what it means it means you could still
hustle in the pandemic you know if you
still get money in the pandemic you
could still build your business in the
pandemic you know and if it's gonna be a
pen generally for the next four months
you know i really suggest everybody
figure out what they gonna do in the
next four months it's always about the
long-run game it's always about the war
see sometimes we have to lose the battle
to win the war I do it all the time and
you have no ego with it you know I'm
saying so as long as you weren't in the
war playing worried about the Bell you
know the battle is just to learn from
the war is what you're trying to win but
you got to really understand what your
war is see I know what my war is my war
is I want to have a television network
any battle in between that I don't care
about it because there's so little in
the morning and when I went at this
television network game when I win at
that game you know what it looks like
the win at television
I'm visualized with it with it what it
looks like to win at television it's a
billy a ruined and I had no partners you
know and that was my dream I might go I
want to do this on my own
I don't have no politics I don't have
nobody's mouth I don't want to deal with
nobody friends I just want to do this on
my own you know I don't want to be about
moles you know I mean like again it's
cool to have done cool but to me what
makes you valid what makes you cold
valid is what you're doing currently you
know it's cool to have done flush and
keep doing it you know I mean you know
like if you have to hit record 20 years
ago and that's the same record that you
performing at your show you know it's
time for a new hit at the end of the day
being at the same exact place for 20
years to me as a loss I think you have
to evolve you know every single year you
have to do new things so that's the
reason why I like in real business
your business has to at least you have
to like plan for your business to grow
ten percent of the year or she don't
have a healthy business you know I mean
so in for me and unless I'm moving
forward like I don't mind everything I
did but I do lose I just I gotta keep
doing lucious I need new work I gotta
have that work and it gotta be good news
like you could you know like if I was
cool 20 years ago and I didn't know how
to be cool now how was that cool you
know that's a fluke that means it was
somebody around me that was cool that
was giving me advice I'm raising a glass
are you guys around the world I got to
get my ass inside because I have babies
to feed I will raise a glass to
blessings and to silver linings and to
all of us by the way trying to have a
little bit of fun smile when we can and
and try and get in trying to find the
silver blessings I'm sorry the silver
linings and the blessings in all of this
and thank you guys for the connection it
means a lot Cheers if you want more
advice wisdom guidance from other
successful entrepreneurs on how you can
navigate the coronavirus situation check
out the video right there next to me I
hope you find it valuable continue to
believe and I'll see you there what
we're gonna see in through Cova 19 and
the crisis